(audience applauding)
- Gosh, hi!
- [Kelly] I love your outfit!
- Thank you, likewise!
- [Kelly] So cute!
- Oh my gosh!
How are you doing?
- I'm really good, thank you for-
- Have y'all, have you ever met?
- I don't wanna do the
thing of where you go like,
oh, like, we've met before.
I don't expect you to remember
me, but we have met before.
(Kelly laughing)
- Where did we meet?
- I never do that to people
where they're like, we've actually met.
- Like, I always like, assume
people don't remember me.
- Me too!
- I had a radio show,
and you came into it one time,
and you gave me advice,
and you were awesome.
And I told you my favorite
piece of Dr. Phil advice,
that I learned early on
and my mom, like, really drilled into me
and it always replays in my head is,
"How's that working for yah?"
- How's that working for yah?
- And, "How's that working for yah?"
It's such a great thing to ask yourself!
- It is, isn't it?
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] It is!
- Yeah, will you ask it for me right now?
- Yeah, how's that working for yah?
- Oh God, that felt good!
(Kelly laughing and clapping)
(audience laughing)
- So wait, do you need--
(audience applauding)
- I just screen shotted that memory.
- Do you need any advice
right now, on anything?
- Actually, yes, something just came up!
- [Kelly] Okay.
- So Dr. Phil,
I struggle with like, regret,
of like, there will be
things I say, stupid things.
I'm like, why did I do that?
- And I'll ruminate on it!
Like, for instance, like,
I just told Dr. Phil
I loved him when I hugged him,
and I don't know why I said that!
(Kelly laughing boisterously)
(audience laughing)
And I wanna know what should I do later on
when I can't sleep 'cause I'm like,
why would I say I love him to him?
Like, I do, but like,
he didn't say it back
and that's weird.
(audience laughing)
- [Kelly] You love what
he does for people!
(Kelly laughing hysterically)
- Like, I just know I'm
gonna be haunted by it later!
What do I do later on?
- You didn't say it back?
- Well, two things, if I had heard it,
I would've been flattered,
but I didn't hear it,
but I'm glad that you said it.
- I think I whispered it,
which is even creepier.
- I tried to have an
intimate moment with you.
What I'm I doing?
- I, love this show.